Hallo ihr Lieben!
Ihr habt ja gesagt ich mach im Moment viel Süßes,
da muss wieder was herzhaftes her!
Und heute hatte ich richtig Lust auf Chicken süß-sauer mit Reis,
also richtig klassisch, schnell, lecker!
Und das Ganze filmen wir jetzt für euch mit damit ihr das auch in Zukunft
immer mal wieder nachmachen könnt.
Für das Rezept habe ich hier eine Schüssel mit Wasser,
das wird jetzt unsere Soße, die rühre ich eben ganz kurz an.
Zum Wasser gebe ich jetzt zuallererst Essig.
Wir machen ja so eine Süß-Sauer-Soße und Essig gibt dann immer schön Säure, das ist Apfelessig.
Das gebe ich hier mit rein, dann kommt noch Sojasoße, Ketchup und
Gemüsebrühepulver mit dazu.
So, Speisestärke auch schon direkt mit dazugeben und einrühren
und der Rest kommt später. Das geben wir jetzt kurz an die Seite und machen
hier in unserem Topf weiter. Da habe ich schon ein bisschen Öl erhitzt,
übrigens: die ganz genauen Mengenangaben, die findet ihr immer unten in der Videobeschreibung
und jetzt habe ich hier Hähnchen einfach schön in mundgerechte Stücke geschnitten
und brate das von allen Seiten richtig schön an.
Das Hähnchen braucht jetzt auch nicht soo lange,
also ich hab das jetzt grad mal 2min hier drin angebraten weil es sehr klein ist, es geht ganz schnell.
Und dann habe ich Zwiebeln dazu gegeben und auch noch Paprika.
Paprika ist optional, das könnt ihr euch aussuchen. Beides jetzt noch so ein bisschen dünsten lassen
und jetzt kommt unsere Soße zum Einsatz.
Nochmal ein bisschen durchrühren und dann einfach dazu geben und einmal richtig schön verrühren.
So, jetzt noch ein bisschen Chili dazu. Ich mache da immer nicht soo viel und Salz und Pfeffer.
Und da könnt ihr auch immer wieder abschmecken.
So, jetzt habe ich das Ganze mit offenem Deckel so ein bisschen einköcheln lassen,
das heißt das Ganze hat sich reduziert, die Soße ist weniger geworden
aber wir haben den vollen Geschmack und wichtig ist dass ihr das mit offenem Deckel macht
und dabei eben ständig umrührt damit es nicht am Boden anpappt oder anklebt.
Und jetzt ist es fast fertig, eine ganz wichtige Zutat kommt jetzt -
ich mach jetzt aber den Herd aus - und zwar Honig!
Das ist sehr sehr wichtig für den Geschmack.
Ihr könntet auch wenn ihr keinen Honig da habt Zucker nehmen, das gibt ihr dann aber
ganz vorne im Schritt mit zur Soße,
das schreibe ich euch auch noch ganz genau in die Infobox. Das rühre ich jetzt ein und dann ist
das Gericht fertig und nebenbei habe ich auch Reis gekocht!
Ta-da und fertig! Ich glaube keine 20 Minuten hat das gedauert
und nebenbei gart ja auch noch der Reis. Und ich rate euch auch definitiv Reis dazu zu servieren!
Das Gericht an sich ist sehr sehr würzig, allein schon wegen der Sojasauce
und eben sehr kräftig auch im Geschmack und daher passt Reis perfekt!
Oder du hattest gerade noch 'ne Idee?
(H: Nudeln!)
Nudeln dazu, dann würde ich die direkt mit rein vermengen, dass man das direkt als Nudelgericht hat,
auch eine sehr gute Idee!
Euch wünsche ich jetzt ganz viel Freude beim Nachkochen!
Falls ihr mehr solcher praktischen und schnellen Rezepte sehen möchtet,
dann hinterlasst diesem Video ein Däumchen nach oben
und wir sehen uns in alter Frische bei unserem nächsten Video!
Tschüss, eure Kiki und der..?
(H: Hamzaa!)
Hamza! Ciao!